[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF JOHNSON: Welcome
back, developers.
Jeff here.
We spent a lot of time
talking about Cloud Foundry,
but today I'm joined by Sharat
of the Stackdriver team,
who promises to show us
how to debug our production
applications with
Google Stackdriver.
SHARAT SHROFF: Howdy, Jeff.
JEFF JOHNSON: Howdy, Sharat.
Can you tell me a bit
about Stackdriver?
SHARAT SHROFF: Of course.
So Stackdriver is a suite
of logging, monitoring,
and other diagnostic
tools, which is primarily
targeted towards developers
who are building and running
their application in the cloud.
It is designed to alert
developers of problems
occurring in production
and easily diagnose
the root cause of the problems.
JEFF JOHNSON: All
right, sounds great.
SHARAT SHROFF: So one good
way to experience Stackdriver
is by actually using the tool.
So why don't I just give a quick
whirlwind demo of Stackdriver
diagnostic tools?
JEFF JOHNSON: All
right, let's dive in.
SHARAT SHROFF: All right.
So let me open up
an application here
that I've got running on
the Google Cloud Platform,
and let's start with logging.
So every developer, of course,
spends time looking at logs.
And what you would see
here is a fairly simple
straightforward log viewer.
And this log viewer has--
of course you can
view logs as they get
generated by the application.
But we have added
a few more things
like the ability to filter
by label or do text search.
And we can do things
like log base metrics.
We can export these
logs to BigQuery.
And then you have the whole
power of BigQuery-- the ability
to slice and dice and
[? permute ?] the data
in any which you
want, available.
And all of this-- the
export to BigQuery--
can happen in just
a couple of clicks.
But one thing that
we observed was
while developers and engineers
take comfort in the fact
that there is data
in logs, they really
don't like wallowing in it.
JEFF JOHNSON: Right.
SHARAT SHROFF: They don't
like spending time like--
you could easily spend
days looking at the logs,
trying to find that one
specification that's
occurring in production.
So with that in
mind, what we did was
we said we can probably do a
better job of pre-processing
these logs as they come in.
And so we created
Error Reporting.
And the best way to
think of Error Reporting
is it's a snapshot.
It's a single
snapshot of everything
that's happening in your
application represented
on one page.
We take all the logs
that's generated,
scan through each of
them in near real time,
and then we
intelligently group these
into different error buckets.
And for each of
these error buckets
we provide some information
like how often it's occurring,
a quick histogram of how
frequently it occurs,
and how severe the issue is.
When it was first seen,
when it was last seen.
We have the ability
to slice these error
groups by time or by versions
and by the application itself.
And you can of course
click on this auto-reload
that allows you to
effectively keep
getting the stream
of information
be updated in near real time.
JEFF JOHNSON: Wow.
SHARAT SHROFF: You can
click on any of this--
let's go ahead and click on
one of these error groups here.
And what you see here,
as you would expect,
is every single
instance of that error
group captured in this view.
So you can drill into any
of those instances of errors
within this error group.
In addition to, of course,
showing you the occurrences
as we described and when
it was first and last seen,
we give you a more
detailed histogram
of where this is occurring.
And we capture the stack trace.
The view the most
engineers are used to
is to basically look
at this mind numbing
view of this stack trace.
JEFF JOHNSON: Yeah.
SHARAT SHROFF: My eyes glaze
over whenever I look at this.
So what we try to do is,
we scan through every one
of these stack traces
and we try to surface
what we believe is the
most relevant portion
of the entire stack trace.
You can always view
the whole thing
by clicking on the Show
All, but the past view
is meant to represent
what we believe
is the most relevant section
where we believe the problem is
occurring, where we
believe is the exact source
of the problem.
So with all of this,
what you have is
developers can get a
snapshot very quickly,
drill into the snapshot
of the specific instance
where the error is occurring,
and have some clues on where
the exact source of that error.
So if you left it at that,
you can imagine a developer
coming to the error reporting
page, going to the logs,
and trying to understand
the root cause.
So the common next
steps we observed
is that developers
would then try
to reproduce that
problem that's occurring
in production on a separate dev
box, on a separate test box.
And then they would go and
insert some breakpoints,
and then inspect the
application state
to try to understand
where the problem could
be exactly occurring,
trying to find
the root cause of the problem.
When they believed
that they found
the root cause, what
developers would tend to do
is to write some more code and
insert some logs and then try
to make sure they validated that
same hypothesis in production.
And so that would require the
developer to write some code,
redeploy the entire application,
wait for the problem to occur,
and then bingo, you would
see the logs and say,
now I'm sure that
I've found the root
cause, let me go write the
lines to go fix the problem.
JEFF JOHNSON: Yeah, a
few hours later, right?
SHARAT SHROFF: It's
a few hours later.
Some places take
a few days later--
JEFF JOHNSON: Sure.
SHARAT SHROFF: --because
the problems might
occur at different places.
So especially you
think of scenarios
where developers have rolled
out only one code to only one
section of the
instances and not all
because it might have some
impact to the application
running in production itself.
So what we did was we
started asking ourselves
some basic questions.
Could we capture the
application state in production
when the application was running
without actually impeding
the application itself, without
pausing the application,
without impacting the
customers or the users
of the application?
We asked ourselves the
question whether we
can insert lock
statements on the fly
when the application is
running without, again, having
to write any lines of code.
So keeping that in mind,
we built the debugger,
the Stackdriver
debugger experience.
The best way to think of the
Stackdriver debugger experience
is, let's take one of
the specific instance
of applications here.
Let's look at this.
We've got what we
have highlighted here,
and the relevant and the
past few of stack trace,
is a specific file
name and a line number.
And that's highlighted to you
as a link, as a handy link.
If you click on that, we
pop open the debugger.
And what is happening
right now, the debugger
is trying to take a
snapshot of that application
as it's running in real time.
And I think, as
we were speaking,
it already took this snapshot.
And specifically
what happens here
is no matter where the next
time this code is executed--
I think this application
has multiple instances.
It's running on
multiple instances.
It doesn't matter
when this occurs next,
it's going to basically
capture the snapshot
and bring it all back
into this debug view.
JEFF JOHNSON: Wow.
So you don't even
have to pick, this
is my special instance
I want to debug--
SHARAT SHROFF: That's right.
JEFF JOHNSON: It's my
entire application.
SHARAT SHROFF: It's
your entire application.
It can run on one instance.
It can run on 100,000
different instances.
There's no problem at all.
JEFF JOHNSON: That's incredible.
SHARAT SHROFF: We will scale
completely without any problem.
And you can also add things
like regular expressions,
which have to evaluate to true.
So you can imagine
taking a snapshot
when a specific
condition occurs,
or when a specific
expression evaluates
to true, because you don't
want to be taking snapshots
for every time that
the code occurs.
It's when the code occurs
and the user equals Jeff,
you can totally do that.
JEFF JOHNSON: Wow.
SHARAT SHROFF: And
when you do that,
you instantly are able to
capture the application state.
JEFF JOHNSON: Wow.
SHARAT SHROFF: We can
also go insert logs
into the application
logs by a simple command.
And you can do that
through the Cloud Shell.
So you basically click on the
Cloud Shell as you're used to,
and then we have very
simple debug commands
handy that you can use.
And you can just go ahead
and insert logs there.
One thing that we also noticed
was that developers really
like to look at their
logs in conjunction
with their source code.
So not only can you
navigate your source code,
which is automatically
selected for you--
the right version
number and file names
are automatically
selected for you--
but we also show you the
relevant logs in this.
And you can use the same things
like filtering that you're
used to in the previous few.
You can also look at
the various snapshots
that I've taken
before, or you can
see the snapshots that have
been taken by other users trying
to debug this application.
With everything that we
have done in Stackdriver,
you can share the same view.
We enabled deep linking
into our experience.
It's as simple as copying
and pasting this URL.
I could just copy this URL
and send it over to you.
And when you open it, you
would see the exact same view,
with the exact same highlights,
with the same snapshot summary.
So that when we decide to
debug an application together,
it's as simple as just
copy pasting this URL.
JEFF JOHNSON: And
that's something
that I traditionally
have to say, OK,
come on over to my box.
I've got it just right.
Hope I don't hit
refresh or something.
SHARAT SHROFF: That's right.
JEFF JOHNSON: That's incredible.
SHARAT SHROFF: It's pretty cool.
We like it.
JEFF JOHNSON: Well, seeing
all these amazing features,
I would love to get these
integrated with Cloud Foundry.
SHARAT SHROFF: Let's do it.
JEFF JOHNSON: Let's
jump right into it
and see how we can
get this thing set up.
So I've got a GO
application, this
is running in Cloud
Foundry as I said.
Can you show me how I can get
it set up with the debugger
and error reporting?
SHARAT SHROFF: So one of
the first things to do
is we first bring the--
your application is
written in GO, correct?
JEFF JOHONSON: Mhm.
SHARAT SHROFF: So
what we'll want to do
is bring in the
debugger agent for GO.
For that you'll
need to modify how
your app starts, to
run this agent instead
of running your app directly.
So at this point
maybe we should do it.
JEFF JOHNSON: All right.
All right.
So I'm going to
pull in the debugger
agent to the same
folder my projects in,
and I'll modify my PROC
file, which specifies
how my application starts.
Instead of running the
application directly,
I will just run that
debugger agent instead.
SHARAT SHROFF: Yeah.
And next what
you'll need to do is
provide some kind of source
context for the debugger,
so that it knows which specific
application version it's
working with.
And this can be generated
with a simple GClock command.
JEFF JOHNSON: OK.
That sounds like
an excellent job
for a continuous integration,
continuous delivery
sort of environment.
SHARAT SHROFF: Exactly.
JEFF JOHNSON: I'll go
ahead and just put it
in my deploy script for now.
So how does
permissioning work here?
SHARAT SHROFF: So if you're
running your application
in GCP, the debugger will
pick up all the service
account credentials
for the virtual machine
it's running on.
But if you're not
running on GCP,
you can provide credentials
to the service account
through a simple
environment variable.
JEFF JOHNSON: Well, my Cloud
Foundry is running on GCP
so I guess I'll get all those
service account credentials
automatically.
But for folks who are running
on other cloud providers,
we'll put information in
the example application
on how to set up credentials.
SHARAT SHROFF: Great.
So now for the integration part,
we'll pull in error reporting.
For the GO version you'll
want to place error.catch
in a defer statement whenever
you want to catch and report
panics.
JEFF JOHNSON: OK.
So I'm going to pull in
the SDK with GO vendor.
And then hop into my
program and import the SDK.
I'm just going to
set up a variable
to hang onto the error's client.
OK, and just initialize that.
So my application is
running with an HTTP
stack that supports middleware.
So I'm just going to paste in
an empty piece of middleware.
And in there is where
I'm going to put that
defer errors.catch statement.
So if an error occurs
higher up in my HTTP stack,
in the Handler, it will
get caught at this point
and reported out.
So with that in place,
all I need to do
is install my middleware.
And that's it?
SHARAT SHROFF: That's it.
So now we can view the
errors that are generated
and you can start
debugging in production.
JEFF JOHNSON: Wow.
Well, let's pop open my web app
and see if there are any bugs.
SHARAT SHROFF: Excellent.
JEFF JOHNSON: So hop into my
application and say, "Hello."
And nothing happens.
So I happen to be trying
this out in production,
but how would I know
if a user hit this,
and I hadn't done that?
SHARAT SHROFF: So there are
two ways you could be notified,
or you know the user hits it.
One, you can be notified.
Stackdriver has
the ability for you
to subscribe to new
errors occurring
and you can be prompted
through an email.
Or if you're using one
of our mobile apps,
then you could get a mobile
notification as well.
You could, of course, always
go to the Dashboard page--
the error reporting
page-- and view it.
If you said that the error
has occurred right now,
we should probably
go look at your inbox
and see if there's a
notification waiting there.
JEFF JOHNSON: OK.
So I'll hop into my
email here, and it
looks like I do have a new
email from Stackdriver.
OK, let's check it out.
So it looks like the
error has occurred,
and I'll just check
out the details.
So on this page it looks like
I can see it's a new error,
it's occurred a few times
here-- with different names
because I've been playing
around a little bit--
and I can expand this and
see my request right there.
That was that "Hello web."
I said I could see
it in the request.
So I better hop
into the debugger
to see what is going
on because I thought
I had some great code
here, apparently we've
got some issues.
Click on that stack trace.
And I'm going to
select my application,
just navigate to that
specific request.
OK.
So I know that my key-in value
must be empty because I'm
throwing a panic there.
So I'll just set a break
point above that, so I can
see what data they're getting.
OK.
So I'm getting that from VARS.
You can expand VARS, and
VARS has values in there.
It's got 2, it's got a
key, and it's got a value,
but why is it empty?
Ah, OK.
So it looks like when
I'm looking at VARS,
I'm pulling out KNV,
but my actual request--
the form side of it--
says KEY and VALUE.
Well, that's embarrassing.
Crazy it made it
through code review.
But now that I've seen a
request with real user data,
I should be able to
fix it pretty easily.
Thank you, Sharat.
SHARAT SHROFF: No problem.
JEFF JOHNSON: And thank
you all for watching.
Check out my application
in the description.
This is a Cloud Foundry
application written in Go
with the Stackdriver
debugger and error
reporting ready to go.
See if you can find any bugs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching.
It's been a great series.
If you've missed a
few of our videos,
make sure to check
out our playlist
for more information about
Cloud Foundry and Google Cloud
Platform.
I especially recommend
this video on Stackdriver.
If you haven't already,
make sure to subscribe
to the Google Cloud channel.
Thank you.